one of the most fun and exciting
applications of confidence recently has
been neural style transfer you get to
implement this yourself and generate
your own artwork in the program exercise
but what is neuro style transfer let me
show you a few examples let's say you
take this image this is a picture taken
a burst and let's say you take this
image this is actually taken from
Stanford University not far from my
Stanford office and you want this
picture recreated in the style of this
image on the right this is actually a
van Gogh's Starry Night painting what
neuro star transfer allows you to do is
generate a new image like the one below
which is a picture of the Stanford
University campus but painted but drawn
in the style of the image on the right
in order to describe how you can
implement this yourself I'm going to use
C to denote the content image s to
denote the style image and G to denote
the image you will generate here's
another example let's say you have this
content image so let's see this is a the
Golden Gate Bridge in San Francisco and
you have this style image this is
actually Pablo Picasso image you can
then combine these to generate this
image G which is the Golden Gate painted
in the style of that Picasso shown on
the right the example shown on the slide
were generated by Justin Johnson and
what you learned in the next few videos
is how you can generate these images
yourself in order to implement neural
style transfer you need to look at the
features extracted by confidence at
various layers the shallow and the
deeper layers of a confident so before
diving into how you can implement newest
our transfer what I want to do in the
next video is try to give you better
intuition about what are all these
layers of a confident really computing
let's take a look at that in the next
video